[Applaudissements]
j'aurais volontiers donné mon avis
géraldine à à raymond bada on n'a pas
voulu montrer le film à venir alors les
4 ans par le commun sont plutôt bien oui
thatcher l'on pense quoi être fait ma
soeur c'est ben beau ce modèle
l'instant
[Applaudissements]
non il prend toujours un simple et où
passe la même chose quoi j'ai grandi à
fos-sur-mer
oui à chaque fois que je vois ça te est
assez rare en pense quoi là je suis
morte de rire mais je m'essaie m'anime
c'est très partie la version l'a pas
encore vu le prix de cette opa
[Musique]
en outre le
donc les scènes de formidable dans le
film et et tout le monde et tous les
auteurs sont amoureux de vous à bosser
ce petit massage vous êtes mais un
massage très chaste un bidon mais bien
sûr on part dans ma tasse on ne voit
rien je vous dis on ne voit rien mais ça
leur salle aura suffi on est encore au
bureau cet après midi et ont usé
géraldine géraldine j'avoue j'en rêverai
voilà qu'elle me masse dans mes séries à
carnon mais c'est surtout ce comme des
fous ce soit ce qu'on aurait pu déjà
boire un café mais je peux me lever et
aux adhésions venait alors à les
regarder sur cette caméra être parce
qu'on n'a rien d'évident tout ce qui est
dedans non mais t'as fait une démarche
est tout démarre ce fait une imitation
doit à eau
[Applaudissements]